So, you found yourself in some draw
down. It's going to happen to everyone.
Don't beat yourself up. It's part of
trading. But let's cover three steps to
handling draw down. The first step that
we're going to look at is take a break,
but don't quit. Now, what this means is
you're still going to do the same
routine. You're still going to go and
look at the charts. You're going to back
test. You're going to trade as normal,
but you either might not trade for a
couple days, or you might just look at
the charts without taking a trade for
that day. What that's going to
accomplish is it's going to remove the
emotions from the equation, which is
where a lot of draw down stems from. If
you have a nice solid trading strategy
or you're finding yourself getting a
little emotional with prop firms, with
options trading, you're trading zero DTE
just because you don't really care about
the money right now, you need to take a
step back. You're not going to quit
trading. You're not going to let it go.
You're not going to slide it out the
door. You're going to take a small
break. You're still going to watch the
charts and you're going to analyze how
your strategy is working, how your
method is working. for today's instance.
Okay, I'm going to take an IB trade. We
went and broke the IV low. Nice retest.
I should have entered short there. We
had a nice retest down. Retest the IV
low. Okay, Trump tweeted something.
Continuing down.
Analyze the charts the same that you
would any other day. Just don't take a
trade with it. There's no problem with
studying the charts. There's no problem
with analyzing real- time market data
without putting real money into it. If
you're finding yourself in draw down
because you're just forcing trades for
whatever reason, trades that you
wouldn't otherwise take, take a break.
Take a day or two, watch the charts, go
for a walk, whatever it might be. And
something that I do that I find
extremely helpful is if I'm having a bad
day, bad two days, bad three days, bad
week, even a bad month,
right after I'm done that trading
session, even if I'm red, even if I'm
green, I get up. I go take a walk. I
take the dog out. Something to clear
your head. Don't look at the charts for
a little bit. Just talk to yourself in
your head. Say, "Okay, this is what I
did wrong. This is what I did right.
We're going to move on to the next day.
I'm not going to look at the charts for
the rest of the day." That's what I mean
by taking a break and not quitting. Step
number two is going to be journaling.
And I cannot emphasize this enough. You
need to be journaling.
I have another Discord open where I go
and type in all my notes. Some people do
it by hand. Some people do it by voice
memo. Very few. As long as you're able
to go back, and this is why I do it on
Discord. I just have another Discord
open that's just me in it. If you're
able to go back and analyze a day that
had almost identical price action to
what's going on right now, whether
that's April of this year or
April of 2022, December 2022, whatever
it might be, where price action was most
similar to what we're experiencing now,
where if we go to the 24-hour time
frame, we're not really having that much
draw down in the market. We're having a
lot of volatility. Market's spiking up
and down based on tweets from Trump.
What you want to do is you want to go
and analyze journals from when you were
trading in an environment that was most
similar to this.
For instance, we had this price action
pretty much at the beginning of the
year, March, all the way until April,
where Trump was tweeting day after day,
tariffs. Do we not have tariffs? Do we
have tariffs? Do we not have tariffs?
And the market was spiking up because
the market was so volatile. Another
simple way to do this is just measure
where the VIX is. This is one of the
things that I do with almost every
journal that I put in. I type out what
the VIX was trading at for a close. So,
we have the VIX trading at 1860.
Last Friday, we had the VIX trading at
29. Friday before that, we had the VIX
trading almost up at 20 again. So on and
so forth. What that does for me is I go
and do a control find search and I look
at the VIX price. Right now, we're
trading at 1850. I do a control find for
let's just type in 18. That will bring
me a wide selection of days where the
VIX was trading at 18 and I can analyze
how either my London 50 model was doing
or another model through Edgeful,
whatever data I happen to be using when
the VIX was trading at that level.
Journaling allows you to remember
memories that you would have otherwise
forgotten because you cannot remember
that much. You can't remember how every
trading day went. But what you can do is
you can log every trading day. Edgeful
does that automatically with a lot of
their reports, but you're not going to
be able to analyze how that single
report traded on that day where the VIX
was trading at this number. Okay, Q's is
trading at this amount. I also plug in
what either Q's or SPY was trading at
for the day. And that really
really helps with being able to
determine how my strategy was doing. Uh
if I go and look at the London 50 for
example and I have Q's trading at 600
which is obviously irrelevant because
we're trading at alltime highs right now
but VIX something that typically ranges
from 12 all the way up to 40 50 60 plus.
If I see that my London 50 model went
all the way down to, let's say, about a
50 to 60% win rate when the VIX was
trading above 20, might be time for me
to slow down a little bit on the London
50 and go back to either just taking the
initial balance trade or looking to just
sell options while the VIX calms down a
little bit. That's what I'm getting at
by journaling. And you need to make sure
that you journal every single day, even
if it's just a couple minutes right
after 4:00 or right after you're done
your trading session, which would be
11:30, 12, 1:00, whatever it might be
for you. Journal your logs. Have a
variable in your journals that you can
go back to and refer to whatever we're
trading at right now. For me, it is the
VIX.
Now the last step and the most important
one. Do not change your strategy. Do not
change your model. Do not change your
concept. If you have a true statistical
advantage in the market like I do with
the initial balance breakout and the
London 50 or if you use any of the other
statistics that are on edgeful that all
have winning strategies. For instance,
if I wanted to take a gap fill today,
had a 63% chance of filling. 61% chance
of filling. If it was a gap up, 63 if it
was a gap down. If I want to take the
initial balance breakout, this one has a
69% chance of happening for a single
break, 29% chance of having a double
break, so on and so forth. Whatever
concept it is that you're using,
continue to bet on the better statistic.
That is your statistical advantage.
That's your edge in the market. I use
the IB and the London 50 every single
day, regardless of emotions. Even if I
feel uneasy about taking it, I should
still take it because that is removing
the emotions from the equation and that
is my statistical advantage in the
market. Now, I'm going to use a coin
flip chart here just as an example.
Let's say every time you flip a coin,
you bet tails. There's a 50-50 statistic
that you're going to hit tails or heads.
So every time, just out of superstition,
you bet tails.
Monday, you would have lost. Tuesday,
you won. Wednesday, you lost. Thursday,
you lost. Friday, you lost. The
following Monday, you won. Tuesday,
Wednesday, you lost. Thursday, Friday,
you won.
If you're just going on the odds, after
4,000
flips of a coin, you're going to have
what should be 2,000 wins, 2,000 losses
if it was statistically accurate or
statistically perfect.
Now, if you start disregarding your edge
and for whatever reason, let's say you
have an edge in flipping coins and
having them land on tails. If you start
disregarding that and after a few
losses, you start betting heads.
Let's say you lost the first time. Okay,
I'm going to bet heads now on Tuesday.
You ended up losing. Okay, I'm going to
go back to tails. Now, you lost again.
Okay, I'm going to stick with tails
because I don't know why I disregard my
statistical advantage.
Now four days in a row you've lost where
if you had just stuck with your initial
concept of calling tails you would have
won one out of four. Now every trading
strategy is going to go through draw
down. If we go to edgeful and we go and
look at cues for the initial bounce
breakout report
it tells you what each day has done for
the past five trading days, six trading
days or whatever it might be.
We can see that it's had two single
breaks and three double breaks over the
past five trading days. Even though the
single break has a very high statistical
advantage, 74% as opposed to 24%,
it's happened only two out of the f two
out of the past five trading days.
A winning concept is still going to have
loss streaks. It's still going to lose
on two, three, four, five days in a row,
but over time it's going to win four,
five, six days in a row a lot more often
than it has losing streaks. As long as
you're trading the same concept, you're
using the same sizing, you're removing
the emotions from the equation,
you're going to come out on the winning
end. You start getting screwed over when
you switch up your trading strategy
while you're on a statistical collection
or collecting data for your statistics.
If I'm only betting tails and we flip
the coin 10 times, I win four out of 10
times just for this data.
If we double that, it should start
getting closer to 50/50. If we go all
the way up to 10,000, it should be damn
near 5,000 5,000.
If you have a winning concept, just like
Edgeful showing here with the single
break, yes, the past five days, two out
of five have won. If we expand this up
to the past 127 days, 94 out of 127 have
won, whereas only 31 out of 127 have
lost. 74% of the time I'm winning, 24%
of the time I'm losing. That's not a bad
statistic to have and it's going to
happen with every trading strategy. This
is why this is the most important rule
because you cannot start changing the
model that you're trading
midway through trading that model or
concept or
methodology, whatever it might be. When
you start switching up on the
statistics, when you start saying,
"Okay, instead of a double break, I'm
going to bet for a single break or vice
versa, that's when you start stacking
four, five, six, even up to seven losing
days in a row. And you continue that
model into the following week, you're
going to lose another five days in a
row." And that's how you create a losing
strategy out of a winning one. You need
to continue to use the same strategy.
You need to journal your entries, your
exits, every trade that you take in
something that you can go and refer your
trades to. And you need to take a break
if you are really getting into a bad
draw down. Just make sure that you're
studying. Take a break. Don't put any
real money in. There's no need to quit.
Just study what you're doing wrong.
Those are my three steps for handling
draw down. It's going to happen for
everyone. Right now, for me, I'm in draw
down on bull. Even though I sold cash
cured puts on it, I'm down about $3,000
or almost 10% on this position.
It's going to happen. I've won on Bull
for the past, I don't know, four or five
months in a row. Just like on TSLL, I've
won 17 out of my past 17 trades. On
HIMS, I've won 14 out of my past 14
trades. I might get assigned on this
one, meaning that one out of my past 15
trades is going to be quote unquote a
loss. Just means I'm going to get
assigned on the position. It's going to
happen. Statistically speaking, I cannot
go on a 100% bender forever.
Those are my steps to handling draw
down. Hope those helped you. If you have
any questions, drop them in the
comments. If you have any video
recommendations, drop those in the
comments as well. Like, subscribe. I'll
see you guys next week.